I believe that this nation should commit  itself landing a man on the moon and  returning him safely to the earth  after thousands of years gazing up in  the heavens and dreaming of this day a  man is about to set foot on the moon  across the world people wait with bated  breath ladies and gentlemen this is a  live signal there he is the shock across  the nation at this event it's just  indescribable  [Music]  the Soviet cosmonaut has become the  first to set foot on the moon you  thought it was about being first turns  out the stakes are much bigger than that  get back to work  we're still in this thing  change of plans gentlemen there is water  on a moat this race will be ours to  fight for and to win and we are not  stopping there moon laughs we need to  accelerate the base you're gonna be an  astronaut and is it Bellona Mars Saturn  stars the galaxy  [Music]  this is not the end of the race  we must keep our eyes to the future  thirty-two  you